(dramatic music)
- It's now time for tonight hashtag wars.
(applause)
(dramatic music)
- [Chris] Yes Emily.
- London bridge is falling
down due to terrorism.
- Yes, points.
That would ruin it.
Yes that's right, Jonah?
- There was an old woman
who lived in a shoe.
Thanks Obama.
(laughter)
- Points, points.
Yes Emily?
- Dry Humpty Dumpty?
(laughter)
- That's why he cracked, points.
Jonah?
- Old mother L. Ron Hubbard.
- Yes points.
Maronzio?
- Jack and Jill went up the hill
but Jack says the sex was consensual.
- Yes (laughs)
- [Emily] Sound great.
- [Chris] Points, Jonah?
- Jack and Jill went up the
hill to talk about the abortion.
(laughter)
- So you think he pushed
her down the hill!
(laughter)
I mean that's just
because of what you said.
- That was not me!
That was totally not me.
- You're gonna take the (mumbles)
you mother(beep) tuxedo jerk.
- I'll forget about it.
- [Emily] It's the suits.
- I'll forget about it, if
you just give me the points?
- [Chris] Alright points.
Points.
Maronzio?
- Georgy Porgy pudding may cry or may die.
- Haha, Points.
Points and Jonah Ray.
- Third eye blind mice.
- Yes.
♫ Di-Di-Di di-di-di di-d-di-di di-di-di
- That's adorale.
♫ Du-Be-De-De-Me-Deh.
- Maronzio?
- Once you go baa baa black
sheep you never go baa baa back.
- [Chris] Yes points.
(dramatic music)
Mike Phriman?
- Just ass league.
- [Chris] Yes points.
(laughter)
Mamrie?
- The Green Throbbin'
- Yes
Points.
Al?
- The Fantastic Foreplay.
- Yes points.
(laughter)
Mamrie?
- Ribbed for Hercules Pleasure.
(laughter)
- Yes points.
Phirman?
- The Apologizing Flash.
(laughter)
- I'm so sorry, this never happened.
I'm so sorry, I'm so sorry, I'm so sorry.
This never happened, I'm so sorry.
Points (laughs)
Yeah Al?
- Scatwoman.
(laughter)
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
- Somebodies filled up the
cat box again, meow, meow.
I'm sorry I just did that, points.
Mike?
- Doctor (beep) Blocktopus
(laughter)
- Oh you can totally do that.
Yes, points.
Al?
- Batman versus the Diddler.
- Yes points, Mamrie, Mamrie?
- The Can I Watch Men?
- Yes, points.
(laughter)
Phirman?
- Thor from last night.
(laughter)
(dramatic music)
- [Chris] Yes Gus?
- Home Ec 405: Ramen as a dessert.
- Yes, points.
Ramen's basically whatever
you put on top of it.
That's what it is.
Yeah points.
Gavin?
- Jazz hands for amputees.
- Yes
(laughter)
Points (laughs) points.
A whole semester of that.
Gus?
- Conversational Dothraki.
- Yes!
(applause)
Points
Burnie?
- Intro to Anal.
(laughter)
- I know.
You do not want to right
to upward division on that.
You probably wanna... yeah points.
Gus?
- Outro to Anal.
(laughter)
- Points, points.
Yes Gavin?
- 101 101: An Introduction to Binary.
(laughter)
- Genius, brilliant.
(applause)
Points.
Gus?
- Geology for Juggalo's.
(laughter)
- (beep)ing magnets, how do they work?
Points.
Burnie?
- Barista training for English Majors.
(laughter)
(dramatic music)
- Yes James?
- Godzilly Vanilly
(laughter)
- [Chris] I want to see that points.
Myq Kaplan?
- How I Met Your Mothra.
- Yes points.
Emily?
- Prime Minister Kong.
- [Chris] Yes.
- He's Canadian.
- He doesn't have as much-
- He's not a King, he's Canadian,
he's democratically elected.
- [Chris] Yeah yeah got it, points.
Points, points.
Myq Kaplan?
- Self aware wolf.
- Yes points.
(laughter)
What am I?
Ooh I'm a wolf.
Yes, Emily?
- Al Frankenstien.
- Points.
James?
- Drakeula
(laughter)
- Oh.
(applause)
- Start it from the bottom of the throat.
- Yeah.
He would literally murder your vagina.
(laughter)
Emily?
- Gluten free cookie monster.
- Yes.
(applause)
Nom-nom-nom-nom cookie bloated.
(laughter)
James?
- Suge Knightmare on Elm Street?
- [Chris] Yes, well done.